[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link joining us today at the round
table of dim lighting is the most
popular Viner in the world and drew
Bachelor better known as King batch King
batch is currently ranked number one
with twelve point nine million followers
on vine you heard it right almost
thirteen million followers with four and
a half billion loops king batch
literally is the king of Zhai he got a
start on YouTube where he uploads
original sketch comedy on his channel
bachelor's pad TV he's got some
incredibly funny stuff on there
including one of our personal favorites
Sherlock homeboy mm-hmm he's also had a
lot of roles in film and television
including MTV's wild and out show times
House of Lies and Adult Swim's black
Jesus but we spent most of our time
today talking to batch about his
bread-and-butter these six-second viral
vine videos now if you haven't seen one
of batches vine videos or a few of them
you are missing out but I'm gonna do my
best because if playing a clip is not
really gonna do anything for you
I'm gonna do my best to just give you a
little bit of an idea of his approach so
there's one called
the set up two guys are talking to each
other one says did you do that robbery
yet he says like I said yeah did you
sell those drugs yet yes they both then
rip off their shirts revealing that they
are wearing wires at which point two
cops come out in a cop grabs each one of
them and pulls them away it all happens
in six seconds this conversationally six
and a half seconds right technically you
can get to six and a half seconds that
is true I've heard that but six seconds
is sort of the the you know what people
still say colloquially now it's it's
much funnier to watch him on loop than
to hear me say and hear you talk about
it but if you you could make a vine
channel where you like explaining his
Valene like play-by-play batches vine I
have a feeling that give me another one
better than just doing our own but no no
no give me how about this one a monopoly
just got real so batches playing
Monopoly with two friends including
DeStorm who we know been on here
biscuits before he lands on go to jail
he then turns to the camera and says I
ain't going back pull
a knife in stabs the different oh yeah
that I laughed it that well that was
good yeah well no they're all they're
great but your money I was was I get it
right was but you should definitely
watch them and not just hear me talk
about them yeah I I enjoy getting inside
of his brain because there's no doubt
king batch is a super talented
technician definitely a filmmaker who
set the template for six second comedy
and he he tackles the topic of race a
lot too
he's got this vine where he's in a
Captain America suit and it's called
Captain African America that's just one
of many seems like something that was
just waiting to happen
but it's like very funny to watch funny
but there's a lot of them they have that
theme yeah I think that the race car was
very much on the forefront of my mind
going into this conversation so I was a
little preoccupied with asking him about
it without actually seeming racist
mission not accomplished yeah I you can
see that it led to a great start to our
conversation but once I recover from
that we also talked about his background
growing up with Jamaican parents and we
got the full complete backstory to his
hilarious vine video where he proposed
to Beyonce at a Clippers game in front
of jay-z in front of jay-z and we talked
about future projects he's working on
including one week and Peele yeah so
enjoy the king batch biscuit
you're wrapping up of a text using vine
headquarters headquarters all right I'm
going I'm going dark for one hour
yeah don't miss me too much you're not
gonna say any activity that wasn't
supposed to be like a racial remark oh
no no there wasn't like a double
entendre I didn't even take it there but
you just made you bet you did you
definitely did that's what's going on
inside so all right so I'm watching back
through the vines and yeah there's that
there's the there's the race theme
sometimes so I think that's what came
out there was like this oh he thinks I'm
a it was like a an insecurity on my part
that's like oh he just thinks that I
might of me like he can't make the race
I can't make a race joke so anybody's
gonna think I did I've just started this
off on the horrible wrong foot right
like this like ultra awkward white guy
foot right it wasn't going through my
mind but now it is how often does that
happen
wow this is a perfect you just said a
record to find that Rhett what do you
mean that
well what does happen to thing okay so
we do quite a lot of research when we
get ready to talk to somebody on an air
biscuit and the thing I always enjoy is
I like to see other people who have
interviewed the person that we're gonna
interview mm-hmm and in the question
that people come up with and they try to
ask they try to ask a question that's
like I want to ask a thought-provoking
thought-provoking question about race
right how often does that's not what
just happened but I know I think it was
kind of the opposite yeah I thought Devo
kiemce joke about race like but how do
you I mean how often does that happen oh
yeah it happens all the time
cuz back when vine first started it was
a whole black people be like why people
be like right agents be like remember
that yeah so we all used to do that and
so I guess I got a couple of vines that
may have dived into that that topic so
you know people always ask because a lot
of my popular vines
those like yeah I don't remember this so
long ago but like I had a lot of fried
chicken jokes a lot of watermelon jokes
a lot of Asian smart joke so a lot of
people ask me about is race and
important topic and why do you talk
about it I talked about it because it is
on everybody's mind like everybody's
trying not to be racist most of the
people you know right so and with comedy
you always gotta talk about or discuss
things that people are are thinking in
their head but too scared to say yeah
there's that irony and then there's that
shock value right exactly you want you
gotta stir things up a little bit yeah I
did one vine it was a maybe like a month
or two ago there was these white people
they're walking we're on the sidewalk
we're all in the same sidewalk walking
towards each other and then they left to
go to other sidewalk I'm like come on
guys it's 2015 and they're like yeah
you're right so they come back to the
corner and I'm like not give me all yeah
so there's things like that that I do in
so it but is there a is there this like
you know every comedian kind of has
something that they're they're known for
kind of something that keep going back
to if it's something like I know that
these racial themed the vines are gonna
get more traction so I'm gonna make sure
that that's one third of my vines or how
does that come in yeah I try to stay
away from him I'll do maybe one every
two or three months you know I try to
stick the original ones like I have a
series called the gas money like I got
you go you got that gas money he doesn't
I got one that's called hey yo ma let me
get your numbers me trying to holla at
girls but you know like every time like
I'll do something that that touches
people so for Father's Day I did a
Father's Day vine it was a white guy
throwing football to his dad and he's
like happy Father's Day dad and then the
death throws it to me and then I thought
to my dad I'm like happy Father's Day
dad and he just hits the ground and
there's no one there and then my friend
he's like yo where's your dad at and I'm
like he went to the store he be back
soon and I just start crying and
add the music music miss hey cuz he's
never coming back now you know that
that's because that's so true to even
though it's it's a little whatever race
is it's true to a lot of people it's not
just black people a lot of white kids
don't have dad's yes well you know so
that that my my reasoning for that was
I'm reaching out to this audience I'm
reaching out to these people that don't
have dads and you also get people at
least in this one instance that we just
watched to say things that they may not
normally say mm-hmm
you were you were on like a local Fox
affiliate and they were interviewing you
right yeah for like their morning show
or something yeah yeah those are always
a little painful to watch like you did
great but it's you know there's always
this disconnect when like you're
watching the local news person who's
like I'm kind of the robot who's been
handed these questions and I have no
clue what I'm asking you about VA or is
it vine yeah but then I was like we were
looking back through I I don't know if
this was on Instagram or vine too but
you got her to be in one of your vines
right I heard of what you got her to be
anchor and she said this just ink King
badge has a tiny pecker oh yeah yeah
yeah she was in the vine yeah how did
you get the reporter to say king batch
has a tiny pecker oh how much I was like
negotiation was there it was it was uh
hey I have twelve point eight million
followers you want to do this yeah yeah
just just say I have a tiny pecker and
then that'll be good yeah and you did
this on the set of the show yeah and so
were there like I like producers like
sent around like she's gonna regret this
or we no see the thing about this they
really are robots like just there's no
one there it's just them it's just like
you two were here yeah amen it's uh it's
the teleprompter and one guy with the
thing and that's it so it's a huge it's
a huge to do no one's there it's just
them by themselves like they can do
whatever they want or whatever you
instead but I mean it wasn't on the air
for them it was like in-between but I
got a lot more views I had have been on
you did it we did it during a commercial
break so we were like rushing they're
like on five four King fetches a tiny
package three and we're live in Los
Angeles California
oh oh it's great so how often are you
putting out a new vine uh they're like a
schedule I'm lazy now I do I do maybe
like when every other day it's not that
I'm lazy its I'm doing a lot of other
stuff like I'm doing TV shows I'm doing
movies so it's hard to like schedule
like doing a vine and then studying the
script and studying these lines you know
because at the end of the day like the
vines they have to come from me living
life you know it comes from real
situations that happen you know and
that's where I draw my vines when I
don't just sit down and say all right
let me think of a funny you don't have
just like a brainstorming session and
it's like constantly on attuned to the
fact that you might experience something
that could be a vine yeah exactly so how
I'm management
yeah well the the the one with even
video games with females are complicated
mm-hmm and she's like adjusting her wee
character right was that from an
experience you were playing yeah with a
woman give us that story okay so it's oh
okay yeah take it from point A to Z okay
so yeah it started off the real
situation I was playing video games with
this girl she anyways so what happened
was we were playing Mario Kart and I
picked my characters boom and then you
know Mario Kart you have to pick a car
you have to pick the parachute to pick
the wheels and she was just spending
forever to do all that so that struck me
like girls take forever to pick to pick
whatever they want in the right in the
regular game and then for vine you have
to take a situation and you have to
heighten it so my heightening it was me
picking my character fast and then her
not only not picking she didn't me get
to the car she's just missing the body
she made the me character skinnier like
changing that I'm in the hair and
everything like that so that's that's
like taking it that's like taking it to
the to the next
level Viacom and I mean before vine I
would never have thought yeah I can sell
that not only in six and a half seconds
but I can sell that with there's like
six or seven cuts right I would never
have thought that was possible yeah yeah
there yet it's it's it's a hard it's a
hard it's a hard process to do cuz
there's always like you don't want to
have too many cuts even though sometimes
I do a lot of cuts
I always watch i watch my vine video
like maybe 50 times for uploaded just to
make sure it's easy on the eyes because
you can get you can get dizzy just
watching cut cut cut cut cut cut cut so
you have to make sure that the cuts they
they match up and I went to film school
so I know about camera angles and all of
that so yeah it's it's a process that I
had to slowly learn and develop and what
about the the captions how important Oh
I mean what percentage of the game is
that oh that's that's ninety nine point
caption is everything like sometimes I
always shoot I shoot my vines and then I
come up with the caption oh really
yep cuz I cuz let me tell you how I and
you know I watch when I'm watching vines
I with yours in particular I really feel
like I've got to read the caption first
something you know when you scroll down
it starts happening and you take it any
like oh I'm gonna start the caption now
I'm watching it now I'm watching I'm
reading the caption right of yours it's
just like I know it I'm gonna get the
caption is gonna be paid off right yep
yeah and that's a that's the thing you
got to do so cheese for captions keep
them short so people can read them cuz
you got six seconds so you want to just
look down and be like boom got it
let's sit now let's watch a video and if
the video is self explanatory don't put
a caption just put an emoji so that
people aren't like trying to look and
see they just see oh it's just an emoji
now let me watch the video so the eyes
can just move really quick so those are
like different tips and tricks
mm-hm but you always come up with a
caption second after yeah exactly
because I'll shoot a vine and I think
it's like you know like the so for
instance the one where the guys walked
across the right the it could have just
been called it's you know it's racist
but
but um but in the when I actually shoot
the vine you know you do some improv
improvisation and you know things are
kind of different so when you edit it
then you come up with a different title
that more suits what you shot you know
right never never be married to a
caption
are you actually editing on your phone
yeah I got iMovie right here so you're
just you just you just keep it all right
there in your palm yep and but you're
banking it like I mean are you are you
playing in days and like shooting a
number of these things or is it really
hand to mouth like I just shot this and
now I'm over here editing it oh yeah
yeah I I shoot maybe maybe three or four
in one setting and then I'll edit them
when I'm when I over to the club you
know that's that's that's how I do it
it's easy and a lot of people come up to
me on the street and like hey man how do
I'm trying to get famous like you man
I'm trying to I'm trying to get my stuff
popping and like I wanna I wanna I want
to help him but then I'm like no why
should I help you that I did it on my
own you know I was in my room just doing
selfies so I'm like I tell everyone like
you can it's up to you you go and you
make a selfie video and you you know do
it do something funny which is code for
I'm not gonna help you it's code for I'm
not gonna help you can go yourself
and that's a related question to that is
when you got the profile that you got
and vine is so collaborative you know
people want to collaborate and that does
a lot for them right and you collaborate
with a lot of people hmm
especially when you have the ability
with the way that you work exactly at
least I could imagine I could you could
be shooting I can say let's shoot
something right now batching right and
like I could think you might could do it
right so I can only imagine that you
have developed the but here's the thing
know here's the thing
when when I was starting out I didn't do
my first collab until I had a hundred
and fifty thousand followers so I built
everything from scratch by myself it was
me and my friends DeStorm power yeah who
else was doing it we did some with
glozell Timothy DeLaGhetto and these are
all people like we had zero followers on
vine you know and we weren't sharing
them to Twitter at the time we were just
shooting it because we didn't know how
to do it so we just went from zero
followers and then it took me
two weeks to get a hundred followers and
then it took me another week and a half
to get 500 followers you know and I
would I was so I was so like crazy about
it
I had a calendar and I'd write down how
many followers I was getting a day and I
was like oh people like when I do this
kind of video people like when I do this
kind of video people like the race
videos and I saw I did this one race
video and I got 2,000 followers just
from doing that I'm like yeah sounds
good like I'm not racist but people want
to see that let me let me do that you
know and then it got to the point where
I I'm I'm mastered and I see what people
like to see they like to see
relationship stuff they like to see
things that you deal with in regular
life that's why you know when I drop my
ideas it comes from stuff that actually
happens to me because not only does it
just happen to me happens to everyone
everyone has related problems everyone
has parent problems and all of this and
then when I developed that when I
studied that I went from getting like
2,000 followers a day to 50,000
followers a day because all these like
websites and best vine compilations are
all putting me on there and they would
put my name king batch this king batch
that you know and I was gonna 50,000
files a day and then I went from 3,000
followers to a million followers in like
less than a month you know right and it
was just from me just doing it out
figuring out on my own you know as
opposed to short-circuiting there's a
short circuit thing that happens when
you just pimp somebody out there exactly
cuz look if I help someone else out and
I give them a tag okay yeah they'll get
20,000 followers but they're if when I
leave and they create content is gonna
suck and people are gonna like why am i
following this guy and it's gonna hurt
them in the long run long run knowing
all that what do you how do you say no I
just tell them I'd say straight up oh
man it see I make it seem like it's a
simple thing even though it's not either
I'm and it's easy just just make selfie
videos I hope when I say I want to do
one with you right now
oh no I they never do they don't no no
don't ask that though that when I do
they'll be like alright let's shoot one
and then it was just do like a a I'm
with King bad you know say what's up and
I'm always willing to say what's up but
like you know no one's ever asked to you
know I got this kid idea and blah blah
and if they do I'll do it it's six
seconds and they're not gonna be like oh
you got to do a backflip here you got to
take your shirt off you gotta kiss my
girlfriend on the mouth no one ever does
that you know so you know I'm always
willing to like you know
what's up or do a quick little quick
little skit like I just say one thing
well that's a good point
the investment is pretty small yeah yeah
okay yeah but then again it's not for I
mean yeah when it's like helping
somebody out but let's go back to just
you and your craft because the I mean
the investment is something that when
you think about your work is tremendous
amount of time and I just imagine even
when you said you're so busy with all
these other things which we'll talk
about there's got to be this pressure
that like a I'm on top I'm really far on
top but there's still a pressure to stay
up there right so you got to keep giving
them something no there's no pressure
because all right so here's it here's
another thing that if you go on vine and
you go in this search thing make sure my
phones on silent I am the number number
five most typed in name on here because
just because of like the videos of the
of me in the past you know so my name I
still get the most followers a day even
though I don't post you know and it's
just because of it has a lot to do with
me being on TV and movies now so people
are like oh that's a guy from vine and
he's on my TV and like someone says like
what's vine and they'll type in my name
and their search oh this guy's funny let
me follow him right so I'm getting a lot
of followers from that just me being on
TV but yeah it's just it it's just your
coast so you're coasting at this point
I'm just coasting right now yeah not a
bad place to be yeah now I am on alpha
cat was telling us about the whole
heater or deleter thing yeah I think
DeStorm told us about it too just we got
into the mechanics with both of them so
we won't make you take us back through
all of that but did you teach them that
no we learn doesn't do good the light
down yeah you delete that and how
quickly are you doing well now I don't
do it anymore because I've kind of like
mastered you know I know what works
we're back in the day I give it five
minutes didn't get if it didn't get the
likes boom out of there do you carry a
police uniform
around with you everywhere because it
comes up in a lot of vines a lot of it
right and so it's like it's one thing
for inspiration to hit okay I can shoot
this but I gotta have my police uniform
now the day storm has his prop closet we
go to day storms house and he's got a
whole bunch of props and uniforms in
there and we're just gonna raid his
closet and does that ever I mean the
whole going outside dressed as a police
officer has ever gotten any of your
friends that you've gotten that to do in
trouble
uh no not the police uniform but they
storm got arrested when Willie got put
in cuffs one time for bringing out a gun
because maybe and it was a it was a toy
gun it with the orange tip and
everything but you know you don't see
that when you're across the street you
don't see the orange tip all you see is
a guy holding the ak-47 yeah we have a
problem
um I want to report this and you know
the cops came helicopters came what was
this this was about a year ago yeah it
was like ten cop cars helicopters it was
crazy and I filmed the whole thing yeah
so white what came of it was he taking
in no no no they just looked at the gun
and they saw the orange tape and they
told her you know we could've shot you
but this is like back in the day when
they're really shooting black people
then man so speaking of thumb that so
what did what did you do with that
footage did that go up somewhere they
went on this I was there was another
social media website that I was on I
can't remember what it was I don't use
it anymore but I uploaded it on that so
it's lost now it's lost footage but if
you find that footage I want to see that
found footage I'll tell you some good
footage yeah Kim Kardashian you well
with you and Beyonce oh yeah
so front row the Clippers game you you
hand her something right and this is a
vine this was this one was huge right
right mm-hmm so give us the story yes
first of all what would the audience see
if they haven't seen it like walk us
through what okay so the audience for
those of you don't that don't follow me
on vine acting batch anyways so it was
me at a Clippers game I see Beyonce and
jay-z sitting down
kneel before Beyonce and I handed her
some toilet paper oh that's what it was
yes because she is on the rest of these
[ __ ] yeah they get bleeped but yeah
you're fine say whatever you want okay
they be poop she'd be pooping on these
female dogs and jay-z looked at me like
I'm gonna kill you after this so when
you say that you can definitely see that
on his face cuz your friend was dominant
or like one of the yes one of the
members of the Clippers
yeah crew they were filming it and yeah
it was pretty it was pretty scary
because like he looks up in mid text and
then looks right looks back down yeah
quite a look and then at that moment it
was it was a it was a quick it was a
quick look but I was just thinking about
all the articles I read of him stabbing
people in the back of the concert I'm
like oh wow maybe I shouldn't have have
done this but Beyonce she look very
happy
oh yes she was so happy she's so nice so
that's what happened but then the vine
loops then cuts to you kind of giving
commentary on the look from jay-z yeah
part of it yeah yeah yeah and because
you have to add a little bit of comedy
to the vine so I was like yeah maybe
probably didn't want to kill me but you
know it's funny if you let people think
that he did right okay so let's let's
rewind a right before you go up to be on
set you're you're just at the Clippers
game because you want to go to a
Clippers game
well the Clippers they actually they
have they gave me season tickets so I go
to all the Clippers games well that's
nice yeah so you're there and you it's
just something you do they tell me they
tell me Beyonce is there if you want to
do something we're not gonna stop you
they they gave you the heads up they
gave me the heads up specifically yeah
Beyonce yeah they didn't mention jay-z
either it's just like no one's thinking
yeah no they said that they said yeah
Beyonce and Jay they're here if you want
to do something and I was like alright
cool let me think of something we're not
gonna send security they're like tackle
you it's basic right right right I mean
a green light yeah oh okay so and she I
don't even think she knows who I am to
this day like I'm sure she's seen the
vine maybe I mean along with 30 million
million okay so how long
for after arriving at this Clippers game
did you did you get to toilet paper and
do this because I would have been a
nervous wreck like so keyed up like it
even in performance mode but you know I
wasn't nervous at all but I wasn't
because she's such a nice person you
know and yeah I wasn't nervous just went
up and I just got on one knee and I was
like even if she is good this is what
this is my reasoning even if she gets
mad at me it's gonna be good television
division would you have done it if it
wasn't gonna be turned into a VY would I
have done it if it was and put it where
just for nowhere just for the moment for
the moment just for the moment just like
for your friends who were there and the
people in the stands would you have done
it for the jumbotron um I would over the
jumbotron I would I would have got a
ring and I would done something like
cool not funny
there's been like hey you would have
been legitimately proposed actually yeah
so I guess what I'm asking is like
what's your like off-camera personality
profile are you they acted like I I
still am going to entertain and I'm
gonna do this this hilarious thing or
this I'm gonna get the center of
attention here or that's like totally
against height oh yeah off camera I'm
boring I just uh off camera I just I'm
creating I'm thinking of stuff to do you
know for when the cameras start rolling
but like you know when the cameras are
rolling that's when I go and I take
risks but off of it no I'm just just
your average Joe the average Joe smil so
knowing that this was going on vine and
it was gonna just totally kill the
internet when it did like that had to
feel good like when you were walking
away like I did it no I'd still have no
idea you never know when a video is
gonna go viral you never know until you
upload it you know now shoot the other
part right there after or did you get
that like I shot it on the way we were
walking back up to the box and I was
just like all right I need something
else it wasn't really all that good so I
was like jay-z looked at me like as you
watch you yeah you watched what you just
shot back yeah and you're like okay I
got my joke I got my button mm-hmm and
did you immediately post it
yeah I posted it right there at the game
it's great no you're still sitting there
you're just watching it go up yeah
watching two games yeah yeah exactly
right and then they had they had my like
when I was down there they had the
camera on me and they had my name but
they spelled to batch ba TCH
but everybody knows it's King batch ba
CH for the viewers out there that don't
know and so right when I got up no one
even saw nobody's even like saying oh it
was crazy what you did to Beyonce they
were just like yo they spelled your name
now and who else is there
Bieber was there with us at the game a
couple of the Viners were there with us
at the game and they were all just like
they weren't even like I just
accomplished my dream and there it was
like yo they spelled your name wrong
found your weakness yeah they found it
so the Clippers just called you haven't
said hey here's season tickets here's a
box yeah and you said okay yes please
yeah that works out it worked out great
give them give them my number let's go
back let's find out how the batch that
we see here in front of us and at the
top of the divine charts you're right
taking over the comedy world how did
this all happen
hey where you from I'm from Florida West
Palm Beach
I was born in Canada raised in the mean
streets of Palm Beach I when did you
move I moved in I was three years old
three years old so can't but you're
technically Canadian I'm not an American
citizen yet I'm still Canadians in a
green card so I could get deported any
minute could you right now are you
working on that they coming in I don't
know no yeah I could if I do something
bad so it's like just like Justin or
drink right yep he's drink American yet
I don't think so yeah so I know he's
really into pools into pools like
swimming pools a lot that's all I know
about Drake so yeah I um I went to
college at Florida State University I
studied finance where your parents like
let's if I stick back there a little bit
yeah my parents they're both drug
dealers
just the finest cocaine no their
accountants they own an accounting firm
but they're Jamaican right they're
Jamaican yeah alright so describe them
like a wheat like okay because then you
say your parents are Canadian Jamaicans
I have no clue what that is
so they yeah they lived their whole life
in Jamaica they went to college in
Canada you're they diverse they've got
like the the accents the Jamaican accent
yeah Mon and did you ever have that no
Mon you never had it no because like I
and I think it's a lot of people that go
through this like when they go to school
like if you have like different like if
you're Spanish or you're Haitian or
whatever you go to school like why do
you talk like that like why can't you
just talk like us and they start making
fun of you so I was like yo dad when I'm
at home speak American
[Music]
they're beating me up at school you
can't you can't be talking like this
verbally beat up or physically beat up
verbally okay so it wasn't a cool thing
have another making parents wasn't a
cool at the time no now it's awesome now
it's it's great because you know there's
no more bullying or is there but it's
like yeah when I was in school I just
was like yeah I want to be like I want
to be like my friends and they talk
regular you know the fried chicken
what is this oxtail with this curry goat
I want fried chicken and watermelon dad
so another racist joke yeah so yeah that
was that was the childhood that I grew
up with brothers and sisters yeah I have
one sister
Christina she's actually my manager and
yeah that was my childhood it was is she
an older sister you can't help you can't
have a younger sister be your manager oh
yeah because that that's why smarter
than me that's like it as older brother
you can't admit any of that right night
it for years but then she solved the
Rubik's Cube in 3.5 seconds and I was
like you win humanity you could do that
spikes in a vine ah yeah almost you get
right to the very
frustrating when you think it loops
before this he almost had the red so are
you what are your parents like now are
we talking like dreads and no no they uh
is regular regular black parents and
still accountants yes still account to
do they take care of your stuff oh yeah
I think I hope they're supposed to be
yeah my sister she she has a master's in
accounting as well okay so this is
there's a lot of family pressure to be
an accountant yeah which is kind of the
exact opposite of what you do at this
point yeah
like ever since I heard grade I was like
I want to be an actor well I didn't know
what acting was I was just like I wanted
to do what Jim Carrey did and that was
like beyond the TV I didn't which movie
were you know Ace Ventura the mass all
the ace Ventura's liar liar all those
movies I used to I used to know liar
liar like word for word mm-hmm and
that's that's how crazy I was with it
you're too young for the end Living
Colour Jim Carrey er yeah yeah I I mean
I saw pieces of it on Napster I used to
download and that's why I saw fire
marshal bill
yes but I never knew was a TV show I
just thought there were little clips on
Napster yeah that I would download so
and LimeWire damn I'm worried
oh yeah yeah so you know I didn't know
what it was but I knew I wanted to be
like that guy were you was this coming
out with being you know class clown
making your friends laugh or was it just
like I'm a kid watching movies and I
want to be like this guy yeah I think I
developed my class clown ways from
trying to be like Jim Carrey like I'll
go to school and start like acting all
goofy like he would do in his movies
like the mask you know and then I guess
that put me as a class clown you know
and it was different because jamaican
comedy it's a lot different than
american comedy it's like you know it's
i don't know it explains just more
aggressive and it was just like i had to
develop my own way of comedy through
like watching these american TV shows
like I would watch Eddie Murphy's
delirious and raw on Napster as well I
didn't even know that it was called
stand-up comedy because there was no
visuals of of the Eddie Murphy stand-up
it was just audio so this is crazy and I
did
know that it was Eddie Murphy until my
freshman year of college when we were
watching it and I was like yo this
sounds so familiar and they were like in
the and then I would listen I was like
yo this is what I used to listen to when
I was a kid because they only had clips
of the of the jokes like the ice cream
joke and all these other Eddie Murphy I
didn't see the good to see the jacket
never sell jacket till my friend to your
college I was like this that's a big
part of that yes exactly
so you know that was that was me growing
up and my parents they're all they come
from the accounting and all that
background so they didn't want me to be
an actor they made me do finance for for
college so my undergrad was in finance
so when you brought it up it was it just
and I think this is probably the case
with a lot of kids I mean right you know
we grew up in North Carolina we wanted
to be filmmakers and when I told my dad
we wanted to go to film school you okay
well I'm not paying for that you know it
I think that when you're kind of outside
of like either like New York or LA it's
like parents don't really they kind of
kind of try to snuff that out cuz it
most of the time it's kind of a pie in
the sky kind of say exactly they said no
one makes it you know you have to be
like going out of a million and you
believe them at that time of you're like
I'm just I'm just gonna find my ID I
kind of did but then I was watching um I
I think I don't know what great I was
maybe eighth grade I was watching some
clips of the rock when he was younger
it's either the rock or Vin Diesel one
of them one of those big guys I think
they're the same person
yeah yeah so maybe someone could find
his clip but they said he said he said I
always knew I was gonna be a star so I
always act like a star and then that
just stuck with me for everything I was
like no matter what anybody says I
already know I'm gonna be you know I'm
gonna be a movie star when I'm older so
I would even though my parents and they
were like you got to go do finance like
yeah do finance but then I would take
acting classes on the side you know to
perfect my craft right so yeah and
acting classes you still grow you
graduated with a degree in finance yeah
but you you were also an athlete in at
FSU right yeah yeah I did the track I
did the track team to like
could have went to I could have competed
for Canada if I want to hide in the
Olympics in high jump yeah yeah if I um
I did I just did sports and you know my
dad did soccer and in high school so I
did soccer growing up I did track
growing up and you know I was good
enough to get a scholarship at college
for track for track yeah and then and
how high said jump seven feet two and a
half inches how tall are you
five eight and a half I round up for the
ladies and say five nine if you had to
do it right to do it right now what do
you think I mean how much is that wear
off over the years um I could probably
get like six eight right now that's you
could jump over me you could Fosbury
flop or whatever it is
yes very flop over ret head if he if he
laid his hair down if you ladies hair
that sounds like a fine but I'm not you
know we won't we can talk about that
later you got it listen you you had a
start this on your own you don't need
gotta do selfies Monday alright selfies
first he could help you but then after
that your vines would suck he's already
told you I told you man but you but you
could have been you're saying you
could've been on the Olympic team yeah
well I mean I take a lot of training but
you but you kind of said you you you
sort of voluntarily backed out it I know
you're suing this thing I always knew
that you know I wanted to be an actor
you know I had fun doing track but at
the same time it wasn't it wasn't a
blast doing you know that what I have a
blast doing is creating content and you
know having people draw towards it
whether it be happy or sad and so how
was that happening in college what were
you doing calm obtained people yeah so I
I was in a couple of acting troupes I
was one called the black actor's guild I
was in another one called bag bag yes
yep it was in another group called 30
and 60 where we performed 30 skits in 60
minutes it was us against the clock
and that was short form comedy and so
like an example of that would be we all
line up in a group and then and then
they would start the timer and then 60
minutes would countdown and then the
audience of a picking numbers they yell
at numbers we have all the numbers line
on the wall maybe they uh 15:15 you turn
over you flip over the 15 card and says
Klondike so we go and we perform and
then and we start to get action whatever
it was like what would you do for a
Klondike bar and then one person goes
I'd read a book another person goes I'd
run a mile another of those skills I'd
help a friend the last person goes I'd
suck good they're like what and then
you're out to the next scene and then
there he was like 14 13 12 and then we
say art 10 and we go to the next kid
like that I mean that sounds like
training for vine yeah some ways yeah I
got to move through this and it can't
take that long cuz I gotta get the other
ones out there exactly yep but it didn't
loop didn't look if and if that one
would have looped would it have been
funnier hmm because that's the real test
right yeah that is really it you got to
see it 10 times got to see it 10 times
and it's gotta keep getting funnier
every time every time does it every time
you watch it's like a movie every time
you watch it like I didn't notice that I
noticed that right there and then you
know so I mean you you had the bug you
were you were deep in this and it's so
it's like improv ya know well we we
performed we uh we practice it wasn't
probably at all we we practiced for a
lake for like two months
okay all that was basically memorized
and planned yeah exactly but an
hour-long show yep mm-hmm
and then what next what what was the
next entertainment thing that started to
get traction for you uh after college
are still in college no stealing college
still in college I did youtube videos my
first one was actually called teos if
you type in is called TLC no scrubs
hilarious I think that's what I call her
hilarious okay yeah I think so yeah yeah
you gotta go out Casper then we gotta go
all cast it all away
what was that it was me doing my first
like music video parody and it's crazy I
don't
yeah it was really bad it wasn't
hilarious
no you were watching like what year was
this this is 2008 okay I made my first
video yeah okay some people are getting
traction on YouTube no I'm gonna do that
I didn't know people were getting
traction on YouTube I heard I just
wanted to make videos and I seen like
some viral videos like I think those
evolution of dance yeah that was that
was the only video that I knew was like
really popping in huh and I was like all
right that's cool let me try and do some
too and I uploaded that didn't get a lot
of views got made like a thousand views
but for me I was like holy Sh yeah a
thousand people saw me you can suck it
that's what I was so you kept you kept
doing it yeah like from there on it your
YouTube channel and you called it King
badge no no that one was called jl0 7d
because I was cursed that's catchy
yeah it was it was my friend's email
address and it was because I was I was
cursing on the channel and I didn't want
my parents to see me cursing and if they
typed it in they would see any like oh
this is bad
what would they have done I mean this
banked me they would have driven what
were they like very conservatives like
no cursing in the house yeah oh yeah I
never curse around my parents even now
even now yeah never but they see your
stuff now yeah they hate it don't hate
it
yeah they do what do they say though
they say Andrew yeah you have to you
have to be a role model I don't know I
don't speak that foolish line now they
um they just tell me they encourage me
to UM to be positive and uplift everyone
but I do and do you engage you say but I
am I mean I tell I have I hope I have a
foundation that's helping people but I I
express myself with as calling a
language but no I tell them it's not
even me like watch a movie you watch
Will Smith he's cursing in his movies
but you don't see him cursing you
interviews you know so I'm like hey it's
just care That's not me Mom I'm
drew that's king bad choice like I don't
know that guy but you Carsten an
interview to right here that's what no
but this is king bats guys let me call
in Andrew hey guys how you doing it's
Andrew M so what are we doing now today
so how often does this come up does this
you have this conversation with you my
parents um she texts me right now is
this liveing stream if this going
straight is this this going right now
put her on speaker let's talk to her
let's talk to my we could ask not call
my mom right now don't say that unless
you're gonna do it I'm doing it right
now let's hope she picks up what's right
Ingrid are you gonna give her context
are you just gonna no okay we're just
going in its hope she's not gonna talk
about my dirty underwear hey mom I'm
getting interviewed right now right
right here in our studio it's the air
biscuit studio mom with rhett and Link
yes yes we do
what do you think about your son's your
son's career be honest mom be honest I
can tell by the tone what do you think
about his videos what do you think about
is what do you think about his videos do
you like his videos is my videos what's
the point one percent we heard about
that what words in particular do you not
like to hear him say
almost got you though didn't I hi mom I
love you I'll talk to you later
love you mom we love you I think it's
really weird you just got your
girlfriend to role plays no that's great
you got a sweet mom now call your dad we
I didn't think you were lying but that
was still very cool to get to give
validations yes yes I don't think it
helped I don't think we helped your
relationship any there but seems like
she's resigned to it though I mean it it
I'm actually the fact that you called
her and she spoke about it like that
it's like yeah this is something we
talked about but this is not a sticking
point in relationship you might move
beyond it yeah yeah yeah yeah
like she yeah she knows I tell her every
time it's like That's not me
it's a character I play you know just
entertaining people you started
investing this character into a YouTube
channel under someone else's email
address yes and then did you switch over
to you youtube channel now it's called
something different yeah and badge no
it's called bachelor pad Jewish pad TV
yeah cuz my king back channel I think
that's where I put my track videos and
then bachelor's pad TV that's right
that's why what I wanted to do was I
want to start my own web series of like
sketch comedy so I developed that to do
that but you know I stopped doing that
stop doing web series and just to like
off skits just like regular one-off
skits so and at the same time you know
okay so you're doing this in 2008 where
you're still in college is you yeah
right when I moved to California in 2010
that's when I stopped jl0 7d and I
started going back to those pad TV and
you moved out here to kind of try to
make it in the traditional media world
yeah and the only way I could do it was
the only way that my parents will let me
move out here is if I took classes so I
said I'm gonna get
my master's degree let me go to
California and do that so I went to New
York Film Academy I did a master's
program I dropped out a semester early
because it was just so repetitive and I
was like come on Denzel Washington he
doesn't have a master's degree you know
let me just I mean I can do a great
Denzel Washington so yeah it's just um I
then I started doing my YouTube stuff
really heavy and I was doing stand-up in
YouTube and then a vine came out I was
just like you know it's a lot cheaper to
do vine videos but what did you think Oh
what was that conversation like when you
were introduced to vine by a friend
right and it was it was a Brittany
Furlan so she was on vine yes so the way
it happened it's like it's crazy that I
think about it now it's like this would
never happened if you know I didn't take
the courses of events that have him so
there was this um there's this comedy
troupe called Groundlings right and
Groundlings i did the classes there and
i met this guy named DJ LaBelle I don't
know if you guys know DJ LaBelle he does
um he does like Dilla parody videos here
it is one called women of LA and I was
in that video and so was Brittany Furlan
but we never met we shot on two
different days so he had a wrap party
for that video and Brittany was there
and she's just really crazy like I
didn't even like the first time he
introduced his I hated my friend preemie
she's like dude I'm like um okay nice to
meet you and it's the whole time at the
party she's every time she sees me she's
like yeah she's sober like she's sober I
liked you huh she liked you that was
like yeah yeah something like that
I don't know but um yeah so after that I
was like you know who's that who's that
crazy girl and she's like all she does
vine videos and at the time she had she
was like the most the number for both
most followed person like she had five
hundred thousand followers and I was
like what's fine and just I downloaded
it like the the week after because black
people always be late racist because
what did you think okay
mine is a six and a half second video
that then loops on itself
this is genius or this is stupid
no I didn't I stomped out yeah I don't
have any opinion on it I'm going to I
did my first video I was just like you
know just filming like random stuff like
and then just I just liked that you can
you can film and stop in the film
something else I was like no one else
has done that before I was like you know
this is cool and and yeah so that's
that's why I started doing it and then
later on I started like let me try a
skit you know and I did like a little
impersonation of something and the next
time I was when I was on set of filming
one of my youtube videos we had a set
there and then I was like alright I'm
gonna like I'm gonna Rob you but then
you take out a gun and then tell me to
put it back and then so we filmed that
little we film that video and then I was
like oh it's cool so the videos like I
started off with they were they're very
bad at first but then I studied and I
said what people like what people wanted
to see and I just incorporated that more
but they were very quickly skit based
yeah exactly where as what she was doing
was more personality based I assume yeah
she did a lot of personality like she
did uh torque a lot of torque videos
like twerking in Walmart and um you know
uh you know she did yes she did a lot of
personality ones but she did a lot of
sketch skit ones as well and then you
kind of got into this group of guys
where you were all trying to figure fine
out right right and DeStorm told us
about the like the vine parties
basically getting together and everybody
makes a bunch of them yeah like how long
you know it seems like the kind of thing
you're gonna look back on it's like
those were the good old days when we got
together and we're figuring it out yeah
we used to film this is when I stopped
everything I stopped you know taking
acting classes I stopped doing stand-up
comedy I start doing YouTube videos and
we would meet up from 9 a.m. to like
5:00 p.m. and just shoot a whole bunch
of videos that's that's all we did we
just shoot the video save them and then
upload the next day and that's when
that's back in the day was when back in
the day we're uploading about 3 videos a
day at that time and would you invite a
whole bunch of really hot girls or would
you just like
find them and just have the meeting
wherever they were because they would be
there one way or another yeah they'd
come like when we had they started
coming out when we had like a hundred
thousand followers like fifty thousand
actually fifty thousand fathers the
girls will start coming out because they
have like what 200 on two thousand two
hundred on like Instagram and Twitter
okay yeah we want to do it so now it's
not as easy right now we have everything
now we have all the followers now
they're just like oh can we can we what
do you think about me like being in your
vine like I don't know think about it
this is Halle Berry you know that's
that's that's where right now but yeah
but so you you stopped doing everything
else to to focus on vine at that time
was that a oh this is gonna this is
gonna be the thing or this is going to
be the thing that gets me into the stuff
that I want to do um know at that point
when I when I focused on it it was just
like I just I don't know it's just like
I really have fun doing this um it's not
like it's wasting my time I'm getting a
lot of followers doing it so you know I
was just like let me just keep with it
to see how many followers I can get and
take over the world and was there any
money in it at that time not early no
there was nothing in it just doing it
just to do it so so you stop doing
things that are potentially making you
some money you're in LA it's not easy to
live in LA right so no but the thing is
I wasn't making any money doing YouTube
either doing YouTube or Stan like
stand-up they'll give you like $50 here
$20 there to you know do some spots but
what was your day job then um nothing I
had nothing I just dropped out of school
and how are you living how are you
living Oh off mommy and daddy okay yeah
yeah I had I made some investments in
college through Apple I bought a stock
in Apple when it was like low when I was
$80 and then at the time when I came out
here was like $600 mm-hmm so I was like
yo I got money saved up I can stop doing
stuff for a while and survive and and
yeah just like let me see what I could
do in this time and I think I think I
had like
six months that I could do it like
straight non-stop everything and I just
did it and stuff started to work out and
what did that when it began to work out
obviously it turned into followers
mm-hmm
but when did the people start calling
you know when we want to put you in this
but I'm gonna represent you know you
don't tell my brands you're talking
about opera like entertain well I guess
both cuz that's kind of two different
things there's the sponsorships and you
know get money directly from it then
there's that other opportunities yeah
they both came about the same time when
I hit a million followers my management
came out of the woodwork hey what's up
man I been everything cool we want to
bring you in the office see what we can
talk about and then also agents were you
know hitting me up you ta caaw me
Gersh all the top agencies were trying
to uh trying to get me to sign with them
and what's that like were you prepared
for that or is it like what do I do it
was like I got asked my younger sister
what I should do it was like revenge
because like back in the day I'm trying
to get like I'm trying to send them my
headshots trying to call him I don't get
nothing I don't get nothing not a thing
but now a couple months later I got a
couple flowers now you guys want to you
know work with me so it was like it was
like all right cool so I let them wait
you know I let them fight it out a
little see which one was the best one
and UTA ended up being the best one for
me and Justin Bieber how did you know
you mentioned him earlier you hanging
out at the Clippers game I know people
like to talk about that and like to ask
about it but I can't not ask right right
because I I think it's just uh oh it's
it's just another point of reference
Beyonce took his toilet paper and it
goes back to the seat with Bieber cuz
they're friends did that happen
because he was a fan first or through
something different of the Clippers game
no Justin Bieber in general oh how we
hang out yeah how did you guys meet oh
so he watched the vine he watches my own
video he was a fan of you of the Vipers
yeah yeah and then what and actually we
didn't meet through that we met because
Floyd was a fan of my vine video so he
flew me out
to Vegas and he gave me tickets to its
fight and you know Bieber walked him out
that year yeah beer walked him out that
year so I met him through through Floyd
and then but he knew who I was through
the vine videos' right and then we all
you know it's a tight family that we
have so we'd all hang out go to parties
together and do that we built a
friendship and was there a point where
you were just like this happened I'm
famous no not not really because of the
way I look at it it's like yeah people
come up and take pictures but to me it's
just like it's a big high school you
know in high school like you look around
you like oh I saw that guy last week you
know oh yeah I saw him two days ago so
you know you have a familiar face there
and they you know take a picture like
you take pics with your friends so
that's to me that's how I look at it
it's like a big high school you know
mm-hm
that's the that's my relation to it what
about snapchat like I know you're on
snapchat King batch on snapchat writing
bachelor ladies um ladies just the
latest so what's your approach to
snapchat because I imagine that you're
vines a lot they're they hatch no I
wouldn't say spontaneously mm-hmm but
like for us if we use snapchat we don't
we don't do vine so we use snapchat as a
very spontaneous way to perform in a way
that our YouTube videos would never
allow us to do but I just assumed there
was more of a competition creatively
between what you do with snapchat or
vine right definitely Instagram right
all right so let's just throw all those
together are you just thrown on
Instagram what's on vine and what are
you doing snapchat yeah so snapchat is
like my daily vlog like I used to do
vlogs on YouTube but you know it's hard
to edit and do all that so I saw
snapchat as okay I can just film what
I'm doing into delete in 24 hours
so that's what I use my snapchat no
sketch based stuff on snow just real
life yeah just real life what I'm doing
who I'm turning up with what dates I'm
going on with my future wife Halle Berry
and yeah so Instagram I use I do that
for pictures of videos I uses app called
shots I do that's like a selfie app so I
do a lot of selfies on that vine video
in my sketches Facebook you know is
everything you guys have stuff on
Facebook that is like a minute and a
half video like an instructional video
different like sketched a longer sketch
playing my character is that only on
Facebook or is that like where else to
know that those are my old YouTube
videos recycling the old seventies they
had like 5,000 views and like four
million views yes and now people have
seen it for the first time it works and
that's why a lot of comments are like yo
what happened to your hair man what's
going on you shaved your head how do you
do this yes yes so it's because those
are videos from like 2008 2010 so it
with all this stuff you know we don't do
vine but we do a lot of that other stuff
and we know how difficult it is to keep
up with staying relevant and staying on
top of all these different things so you
kind of gave the impression in a
previous interview that with the vine
stuff it's just like no I mean I'm just
filming it and I'm editing it on my
phone but is it just you and your sister
and like or what's the team behind yeah
your team is me my mom my sister my dad
and you ta that's that's a team right
there
so for int and for your content that you
put on my vine videos you you it yours
basically saying you can kind of do you
get help from friends but in terms I
don't get someone to edit your giant
videos myself yeah right on the phone on
my phone yeah so like like I said like
if I'm going to an audition or I'm going
to you know the movies or something with
some friends I'll be editing my vine
videos right I think the big question is
when is Sherlock homeboy gonna come back
I love that great I want to turn it into
a movie but copyright issues with
Sherlock Holmes yeah really just a
parody man this
misspell Sherlock get a really good fair
use law yer and just yeah do it man
listen all right I'm gonna cut right
this with you man right now
yes Sherlock homeboy meets her lock girl
homegirl I don't know there's like a
there's like a female alter ego right be
Halle Berry
she'd be ended up the pipe okay so the
start like homeboy I'm just gonna geek
out on this this character a little bit
there's two episodes on your YouTube
channel right mm-hmm
and this was before vine took off or
like at an early stage of I where it was
like in parallel right right I guess
it's my way of asking what how do you
view YouTube are you gonna do any of
that is it is it necessary and I love
you too but I love actually love YouTube
more than vine because like YouTube you
can show you can show like talent on
YouTube you know you can you can really
like take your time and show emotion and
you know really tell a story whereas
vine is just like you got a boom boom
boom and you'll be over the top and all
that so so yeah you're frustrated
creatively with the limitations of vine
no not at all because I can do you know
you can do whatever you want I choose to
do the vine videos I have fun doing them
I have fun doing them so you know I make
the vine videos and then when I have
time I'll go back and make you YouTube
videos as well but if you had to choose
if you were forced to choose you can be
number one on vine forever to keep doing
what you're doing or you can pursue this
traditional whether it's YouTube or
whether it's film or TV story based
character based stuff which one would
you do money is not a factor well see
it's a politic game because if I wanted
to get offered the roles on the TV shows
and I'm getting offered I would need the
followers even though you know that even
though you have the talent you still
need the fanbase
but let's take that out let's write a
blank check oh you too yeah so from a
creative standpoint yeah
because as you wanted I went to film
school I studied studied everything
about you know directing producing I do
that also if you look at my youtube
channel those are the
that I wrote directed and produced and
it's just it's it's a great feeling when
you take something from 0 to 100 real
quick right but so what are you focusing
on now because it would seem I would
assume that you could pour your finances
into if you want to do a self-financed
something on YouTube you could certainly
do that at this point oh yeah definitely
so is that what you're doing or is it
more of the traditional break into
movies kind of thing what what is
where's your focus yeah right now it's
more the traditional I'm actually
developing a show with key and Peele
right now a sitcom that we're gonna
pitch the networks and the end of next
month I'm doing a move with Martin
Lawrence I just got two scripts gonna
see which one that I like the best out
of those and you would just be acting in
that yeah acting in those yep as opposed
to I didn't know if there was like a
directing component to any of this or a
writing component no I won't start
directing traditional media until about
maybe three or four years then it'll be
big blockbuster movies yes um so yeah it
you know it and then I'm I have another
offer to do it another like a you know
adequate budget movie starring myself so
yeah I'm doing a lot of traditional
media so I don't really have time to uh
to do the YouTube videos as much as I
want and same with vine like it's hard
for me to you know find the time to do
vine videos as well so I mean you're
getting the opportunities that you that
you want but it's interesting because
like when I look at sure like homeboys
like I can immediately see like the the
next step from that if that's the only
thing I saw in terms of you being like
it's clear that you're a star a movie
star when I watch that like if I hadn't
seen anything else it's just automatic
but the vine videos' it requires it's
like okay isn't there a question of well
are they only listening to me because
I'm I have so many followers are they
only hiring me because I'm popular on
vine but there's but creatively there's
no crossover here yeah exactly you know
it's it's nice that you
the comedic chops to be a great actor
mm-hmm but that's it isn't it
frustrating that you're being hired just
because you're popular nor is it Bo I
mean not at all because you know I I
went to film school I'm dying over here
I went to film school and I studied you
know the craft of acting before you know
I stopped everything like I know you're
good at it but right but isn't there a
chip on your shoulder no not out because
like you know I I do the videos too I
had to do the videos to get popular so I
could get offered these roles and then I
used the talent that I have stored up to
when I get the rules so when I get the
rose to perform when I'm on set so it
all happened like it all happens hand in
hand so you know a lot of that's why I
think you know I hear a lot of rumors
about you know we give YouTube stars the
opportunity to act in these movies and
they mess it up and that's because they
don't have the training the training of
the craft and they're not ready yet you
know so it all it all works you know
that when you take advantage of the
opportunity you're gonna show up and
you're gonna deliver exactly so you're
not yeah not scared I actually did
actually did a drama movie my first
drama movie that will come out in 2016
it's called shot-callers so you know
that that's me doing some serious acting
and for two years straight
that's all I studied just drama no just
crying in classes and all of that stuff
so you're not funny at all I'm not funny
at all do you cry I to cry do you bleed
I do bleep I bleep blood and it's okay
so even now you're already branching off
into just drama right but isn't but it's
an actor path exactly at this point yeah
a directing that will come back in
mm-hmm what's the key and pill show it
can't peel I can't really talk too much
about it I could say it's based about
cops hey I need that cop outfit for what
uh it's just some silly TV show bro so
it's not a it's not a sketch series it's
a it's a scripted yes
yep mm-hmm that's exciting
yeah it's gonna be great and are they
gonna be in it too or they just behind
the scene they're just producing it
executive producing it putting their
stamp on it yeah okay that's a good
stamp to have yeah yeah listen man it
was it was a cool to hear your story and
get to know you and we're super excited
and like to be here yeah so so let's see
it we'll see you at the next Clippers
game
oh yeah would Beyonce will be above the
box like in the upper deck well we'll
throw something down to you we'll be out
front waiting for you to walk by and
we'll hold on our hands for a few extra
ticket
thanks for coming in ah thanks for
having me and there you have it our
conversation with King batch tweet at
King batch and let him know what you
think about conversations it's spelled
like Bach King bee ACH and yeah I might
have thought it was Bach first time I
the first time at least a cinema one
time and after that got it right maybe
it was yeah I had to hear somebody say
it but when I read it it was King Bach
so that's how you type it when you tweet
at him hashtag ear biscuits but when you
see him on the street just say hey
what's up - what's up badge now I find
it interesting he's funny everywhere he
tries to be funny
oh yeah but he has hit this sweet spot
with six seconds but I think that we
should potentially get him to be
involved in our new venture the new app
that we've come up with twig one second
video yes we have as opposed to just
going down to five or four let's just go
all the way to one who else is gonna
compete there right maybe maybe maybe
like photo sites potentially I don't
know they got no photo shows is no
second it means this so it's just a one
frame I'm talking right full and maybe
30 frame a 60 we did everything's in 60
frames so you get 60 frames 60fps like
the news
thank you yeah I think working we're not
competing with pictures but we're
competing with the Jews Twigg anyway so
happy to announce our new app twig and
matches featuring batches number one on
twig he's all out soon to be number one
on twig right he's he is I mean but he's
on top of the world
what I need sense is no pressure I'm
just so far ahead I'm joking but I think
he actually would be funny in one second
that's the funny thing is that if you
told him hey man there's this new thing
when you got to be funny in one second
he would figure out a way to be funny on
one second oh sure he already knows it
you don't know he's like you are yeah
I've already got 20 things planned
because I knew this was gonna happen and
there's people who have already planted
it so like our twig is gonna be late to
the game your twig is probably already
an app and we and we've like sent people
over to it now you know I think berry
should be number one on twig is gonna
create that account right area with the
e I get it
I think it's berries actually oh there's
like two guys named berry on the same
account and their number one twig they
could be number one and two and they
alternate between he's on time and we
decide no we decide who's on top man no
that's not how it works is whoever gets
nice loops oh okay hey is it gonna look
doesn't loop it's one second in it
doesn't breeze is that the increases and
you can come to never and then it
disappears cuz it's like snapchat it's
up for one second and then it disappears
try to be funny on that batch I bet you
can mmm me too
all right we'll be back next week oh
well with another new invention or maybe
we'll just do another year yeah let's
just do that instead yeah okay
[Music]
[Music]